so um
you asked me
so what's it like to cross-dress when
you're a straight male
so my sebastian is uh my male side
sebastian kane is a straight male he
dates um
women
exclusively stephanie my female side
is a straight female
i don't know what that makes me with
regard to my new wife if that makes me a
lesbian or straight or whatever we're
calling ourselves pansexual let's just
keep it at that but what i've come to
realize in in being a woman i dig it
it's fun i love the fashion i enjoy the
you know taking an article of clothing
that has no pockets in it you enjoy
being a woman i love being a woman it's
a lot of fun
i'm in touch with my female side now
a lot of things that women have
complained to me about i now understand
and
you know and i want to do something
about it
you know i've experienced uh serious
discrimination in los angeles by being
trans i've walked in
places that you would not expect that
they would
um
someone would be attacking of you and
i've had security guards
like lock me into the bathroom because
and telling me there's a time limit i
mean crazy stuff
just because i'm trans now it's true you
know
i'm not walking around dressed as miss
conservative
because i think you know if you got it
flaunt it you know look hot
you know i just designed this thing look
at that cool thing
this is a necklace that i instead of
going around my neck i tied it to
another necklace and so it hangs down on
my belly button with this diamond in it
so i don't have to get a pierce
belly button
so there's like all these cool things
that i'm discovering that i just didn't
know
just i still got to do the face makeup i
i don't really know how to do that
um i'm just barely learning how to do
lipstick so
you know good thing my uh my new wife
knows a lot about makeup that'll help
yeah
like a little bit of entertainment is i
i'd go with
young females and trans
um when they do the right the host role
yeah they walk the blade
it's sort of like
think of it as kind of undercover uh
bodyguard work but i still get the
thrill of getting out of the car
sometimes these guys all want the you
know three ways with the two girls so
so uh
i call you stephen uh steffy steffy yeah
well
i don't i haven't got
so check this out steven's dead
he died in a plane crash in nepal and uh
eight years ago found his dna on the
boat on the plane and i was during the
film we did called state of control
so i was one of the benefits i got was i
got to die
and then what i did is i created these
characters
sebastian kane
is my male side and steffy is my female
side and uh instead of like what
stallone did with rocky where rocky
lives in a movie and then that's it
um
sebastian kane can lives i mean he's
been alive now for almost 10 years i go
by sebastian kane i love sebastian kane
i make every decision based on what he
would do
and um
you know his background which is very
similar to mine
um
but i left with kaplan kind of like the
few bad things that happened in my life
as a way of healing it
and uh
and then i was playing making these
three movies involving that character
the viking was the first one
and um
yeah i went for it man i went for the
whole thing i worked on the saw movies i
was one of the guys that wrote the
distribution deal for saw
and um
represented one of the producers so
you're a movie producer yeah i'm a
full-on movie producer i've got 24
uh producer credits
producer and executive producer credits
all right so let me just back up yeah
you grew up where um
san marino primarily
but i was born in monaco
south of france it's south of france
north of italy yeah what was your
childhood like
um
it was perfect you know i got to spend
about six months in monaco each year and
six months in
um san marino at my parents business
partner's house in san marino and they
were a month in a hawaii and a month at
boy scout camp that's where i learned
how to shoot this boy scout cam
and um you know i was a little kid so i
shot a lot
you know and i'm a very proficient
marksman and very patient
and
when
when i was in college just after i got
out of ucla
my best friend died of a heroin overdose
and when she died
at first i felt you know horrible you
know but you hear about this drug heroin
and then i found out that what had
actually happened she had become
addicted and she got raped to death
in a motel in compton
and when that happened coupled with when
i went to monaco to collect my
inheritance
my trustee admitted that he had
squandered my parents entire fortune
except for their flat
so that's all i had was a flat i had no
money saved
for uh law school or anything else
and
between her death
and
the theft
it just kind of put me over there and i
hadn't i realized i had no skills in the
dark arts nothing i i was a [ __ ]
and i liked that feeling
so i applied to the various military
branches but i'm too independent a
secret thinker for that and i also don't
like the commitment i like to you know
make my own decisions and
you know and if i make a decision that's
wrong i take responsibility if i make a
decision that's right and i have to
change it up the line of scrimmage i do
that whatever's the best decision i'll
make and so the only thing i could find
that really worked was this blackwater
gig so they gave me a choice of stations
and and my job was before you go into
that
tell me about your parents your
childhood yeah so um
you know so i went to a private school
in monaco and i went to a public school
public high school in uh in san marino
san bernardino high school
and um when my folks died i came to live
full time
with their best friends with their your
parents died when when i was 13
yeah in a hot air balloon accident over
the loire valley
in south of france
and it was uh
you know last thing i remember was
seeing this big bird and
it clipped the fuel line when the wind
changed
clipped the fuel line of the balloon and
the
fuel sprayed all over my parents and
over the pilot and it ignited
so the blast blew
and you know
lit them on fire and it blew me over the
side
of the gondola
and
i woke up
seven weeks later in a french hospital
my mouth was wired shut they they had to
rebuild my entire face from here all the
way through it's all titanium
primarily i still can't feel my chin
makes kissing rough too
but um you know as it were i generally
healed i have 680 stitches in my face
can't see any of them they're all on the
inside
um
and
you know and i was an orphan i wasn't
alone because my parents business
partners
took me in like i was their oldest son
and their their next older or their
oldest son was two years younger than me
so um
i really didn't skip a beat when they
died other than really missing them
and what's one of the sad things is that
you know as i've gotten older i i you
know i forget you know and
there's um
it's hard because you see your parents
faces that are kind of
you know um disappearing you know you
were holding when this happened 13 13.
yeah
yeah it was um
it was definitely a life life changer a
lot of ways i realized i truly was on my
own
um so i'm either
you know a leader or i'm a lone wolf
typically when i you know i'm doing what
whatever it is i do
and um
it's also allowed me to to sort of like
live life on my own terms i don't work a
traditional job at all you know i create
intellectual property that's why the
symbol of my company
is the skull
because without your brain
your collection of organs you lose the
essence of you who you are and so um the
brain is the only organ that lives
within an armored casing
so i have
the skull
you know yes it does look badass
but more importantly it's um
the repository
of knowledge
so i wear the i have this
necklace i wear and i wear the
skull rings so always remind me of the
power of the mind and uh you know and it
suited me well plus if you get in a
fight it leaves a hell of a mark you
know it's got the whole logo and
everything you got a settlement from
that accident
um
did not get a settlement i inherited
their entire state and it was
significant there was um
many many many millions of dollars but
all the cash the stocks and the bonds
were all dissipated by the trustee
so he stole my money
and i told him when i left his office
that day i said i'm going to be back in
three years time
and it would be best
if you
you found that money for me
so you know i threw myself into that
blackwater job you know i
i think i did a really good job
um president reagan summoned me to
washington after
my time on the war on drugs was over a
private lunch with him and he gave me
you know
an award a very high civilian award
for my service
and
you know
you know my best friend at the time was
my spotter he was killed in action on my
last mission you know after 109 halo
jumps
took an 1847 around his
back to his spine a little stomach out
the front
and and i didn't want to shoot anymore
after that because i was pretty
dependent on him
and he was in the jungle with me for two
years
you know and it's these conditions are
you know not like american sniper where
you have ground support and logistical
support this is
hit your targets
go to extraction point a if you miss it
you got a 15-minute window you miss it
you go to extraction point b the next
day you miss it you run you swim
whatever you got to do but we they don't
come back for you this isn't you know
the marines or they don't leave their
men on the battlefield we live in all
over the world all the time for
companies like blackwater which there
aren't many i mean blackwater is really
the major one that people remember
and um
and you did that for how long
i was uh
a shooter for two years
and i did something called psyop
psychological warfare
for
seven months of training
and uh
and then i did five months of actual
field work at uh
black sites cia black sets so they're
secret um military bases where we you
know interior prisoners that
go beyond the geneva convention
so the methodology is um
is pretty intense
you we can't not get this information
yeah so
even though it's illegal it's also very
um
necessary
because of the heart
potential
and after
that career you became a fan i went to
law school i went to law school yeah i
went to law school at loyola in los
angeles
and i went right into working at a law
firm so i was traveler and i tried a lot
of cases and
arbitrations and a lot of
had a lot of clients
and um but i realized pretty quickly i
don't really like being
the lawyer so even though i did it for
20 years 10 years as a litigator trial
lawyer and 10 years in entertainment and
intellectual property
primarily
i got to really see a cross-section of
business
everything from
beauty distribution companies dot-com
entrepreneurs
pornographic uh com you know companies
that make uh porno um
straight production companies actors and
a whole bunch of just very
different types of clients because i i'm
very personable with people i care about
people very much
and um
and i wanted to
you know make up for
you know some of the things i did when i
was younger you know
there's some guilt that goes into that
i wouldn't say to them a bleeding heart
but i'm definitely a free thinker and
you know and i'm totally non-judgmental
everyone is on their own merits i run my
company as a pure
um
as a pure meritocracy you only everyone
gets minimum wage and if you do
something that earns money for the
company i give them bonuses including
myself
so um
it incentivizes everyone and so
in my
apartment right now i've got 10 people
working in the apartment they sleep
there eat there
they walk my dog they're literally
being fostered by me in the same
environment i'm in
i do not mind living like a spartan i
have no car and no tv
i don't buy anything not because i don't
like material things but because they
seem to just come to me
and i don't know how to explain it
it just has happened
it's the weirdest thing ever so you've
been working film production for how
long i've been doing film production
since 2000
and uh my first movie was terra track
with john ritter and brian cranston it
was the film that got brian the role on
breaking bad
of walter white
and um did you want to give your name so
people can look you up because
everyone's going to say you're lying and
i've looked you up and i say that you're
legit but yeah yeah uh it's steven g
kaplan rainstorm entertainment
and you've done other films too i've
done a lot of films i did uh the big
empty with john favreau
kelsey grammer daryl hannah
and beach sean bean
terrific film very watchable i did the
definitive film about the f word [ __ ]
that i sold mark cuban
and uh one of the few
it holds the world's record for the most
f word said in one movie
beating out scarface
it's a dubious honor but somebody's got
to do it so i'll take it
and
it features an interview with hunter s
thompson that we did three days before
he killed himself
and that interview's three hours long is
all over the map and that we cut that
for the you know the some kind of a
anniversary
um and then i just went i just did a
whole bunch of movies so i've done a lot
of movies and uh i work on
film all the time and you're currently
still doing this yes i took four years
off i retired because i had a swat
standoff
it's crazy but i
moved in this place in hollywood called
the camden
and it was beautiful it was a brand new
building and i decided to write a script
that fit the entire building so i used
the entire building as a prop you know
as a location
um i got my permits
and i would write the script in the
morning i would pull money out of my
accounts
set up the crew for that night and i'd
shoot all night and i was also i was
producing it directing it financing it
wrote it and starring in it
and i had
two other actors one played the wrangler
which was mojo my little puppy's handler
and the other one played my uh my
spotter who comes back to help me when
it turns out that this guy who's been
retired for years
his cover gets blown
he's gone from being a cia sniper
eliminating
drug lords in southeast asia
to being a movie producer and he has an
amazing life you know he's got a
beautiful young girlfriend this amazing
dog and everything he wants and then
do the carelessness of the manager of
the building they blow his cover
and all the bad guys descend
for revenge and he gets called from
washington they say
you got to get out of there you got 24
hours you can't hold them off
so you're going to run or you're going
to fight
so he makes a choice to stand his ground
and he fights and it is bad ass balls to
the wall action
i got the building security guards to
play the act to be the security guards
in the movie so they're all handling my
guns
all props
i'm using every part of the amenities of
that building for the film you know i
felt like an apache i'm using every part
of the animal
and the billionaire did it so they
started calling the police on me
so believe it or not in 120 days
the police came
45 times
to [ __ ] with me and arrested me 18 times
in that 120-day period i've never been
arrested that'll slow down production it
did
but that wasn't what made me uh go on
hiatus what made me go on hiatus is that
someone phoned in a a
complaint or a incident report that i
had a 50 caliber barrett
sniper rifle which i did in all fairness
i did but it was a um i'd modified it to
fire pellets instead of the the you know
the shells
and uh i had
they said i had a bomb in a semtech you
know which is a military grade explosive
could take out let's say 10 square
blocks
they thought i had that
and then they thought i had hostages
so based on that those reports
they brought in everyone it's the second
largest swat standoff in california
history
375 police officers surrounded my
building
in 10 city blocks evacuated the w among
others
and it was all six swat teams so when i
looked out the window when they were
calling my name on the megaphone
i look out there's an armored car in the
middle of the intersection at argyle and
there are snipers everywhere those
little green dots and red dots
everywhere in my apartment and the only
living things in there were me and mojo
so i'm like
you know they said surrender come out
with your hands i mean literally it's
like a movie or something and like going
this is all being filmed because i had
my cameras rolling there's helicopters
filming there's police helicopters
filming
and they've got
you know hollywood on this lockdown
and like
so when they said surrender i said
nah i don't think so i think i'm going
to stay alive
why don't you guys come back tomorrow
and i'll surrender when it's light out
but otherwise
you know
bye-bye
so i
stay inside
and for
from five o'clock in the afternoon when
it started until
2 45 in the morning
they negotiated with me trying to get me
to surrender peacefully
i'm assuming they knew about my past
because they certainly were acting like
i had the capacity and capability of
doing the things that they thought i was
capable of doing because i am
i would never do that i love my country
and i love you know america and i love
you know
i think everyone should be left alone
and have happy lives
so i'm just making a movie minding my
own business nothing illegal whatsoever
was in that apartment
so at 245 the head negotiator for the
swat teams
offered me the following as a peace
offering if i would surrender
they would bring me a burger by any
hamburger chain i wanted
and of course
you know i was making films so i had two
big refrigerators full
of food for my crew and i had another
one
that had drinks in it so i literally had
three i could have survived for weeks in
that place
and i'm looking down at them like are
you guys idiots but i get it you're
trying to build some empathy with me and
some some uh like trust
so i said fine
i want to surrender i want to be out of
here so tell you what
bring me a double double
extra fries
uh animal style and extra tomatoes hold
the pickles
i want some fries and a chocolate shake
if you bring that put on a tray right
outside my door no police officers on
either side of the hallway except
cameron's in there i'm going to pull
that tray in i'm going to wolf that
stuff down then i'm going to call my
assistant you let her up so i can give
her mojo
and then in the morning i'll surrender
and they said well well how about now
and i said fine i'll surrender now but
only one officer
take me into custody
so they agreed
and i thought it was over
20 minutes later
they call my name
okay we got your burger
come out
i look out the window and like that
movie say anything
the negotiator is holding up two bags of
mcdonald's
and i can't stand mcdonald's
all right i worked you know a friend of
mine did a movie called super size me
this would kill you so i said
you know guys you've broken every
promise you've made to me in the last
four months so i'll tell you what i'm
not coming out change my mind you have a
nice day and they said if you don't come
out in one minute
we are going to send in tactical
like
really you're going to send in tactical
oh no
i literally in one minute
pulled out my bug out bag put on a
yellow chemical weapons combat suit
a gas mask and i went into the safe room
we had built in the apartment
for the movie
i had a full
you know safe room it's sealed
there's a a damp towel underneath the
door
they opened fire on us with flashbang
grenades
tear gas pepper spray
every 30 minutes
for the next eight hours
they did
mojo and i were took a nap for like
three hours
and then um i read a book a little bit
um
you know i had my wi-fi so i was able to
like you know go on the internet and
surf that
um and at 11 in the morning
the next day
i heard this weird sound and it sounded
like a tank because it was it was a
little mini tank that they had wheeled
down that hallway and it attached a bomb
to my door blew it off the hinges came
in destroyed everything else that hadn't
already been destroyed of mine and then
use the battering ram to punch a hole in
my safe room
and a little camera comes in
and i hear this guy go holy [ __ ] when he
sees me in the chemical weapons suit
that concerned them a little bit i think
so um
i surrendered to the robot i the robot
backed up i followed the robot the robot
tipped over
and
they said look
just go out in the hallway and put your
hands up and lie on the ground
and i i'm not doing that you guys have
guys and machine guns on both ends of
that hall
so tell you what i'm going to stay alive
when you send one guy to my door and
knock very nicely
and bring my assistant up so she can
you know get mojo
i'm happy to surrender it'd be great so
that's what happened they sent a guy out
and i just stepped out to any time um i
did i they put me in solitary
confinement twin towers
for
almost three months
23 hours a day locked down as a high
power because i took on the police
they um they denied me my right of
counsel
they um
it was a horrible experience being in
solitary that long was horrible that my
bail was like two million dollars you
know like 1.8 million dollar bail so i
couldn't afford to bail out
and after uh
while i was in there you kind of feel
like you're going to go crazy it's a
little tiny room you know your cell
so i wrote a script called seal
and that's how i
survived solitary confinement so
i wrote seal
on the back of the christian science
monitor with these half pencils that
they give you they don't give you a full
pencil half pencils i hand wrote it long
hand
and then um
after the solitary confinement i spent
like another month until they had
dropped enough of the cases
and i had to have surgery for a medical
condition i developed
that they um said we're going to put you
in rehab
i'm like for what i haven't been on any
drugs for four months there were no
drugs by the way in the apartment or in
my bloodstream when this happened i
wasn't on any drugs but they said we're
going to send you rehab
and then you're going to go to sober
living
and then you go back to prison so we can
assess you for uh suitability for
probation
which i had to do after they made me
plead guilty to two violent strike
felonies for criminal threats that was a
compromise i took the deal to not go to
state prison so the only thing i had to
do was 13 days at wasco that was it in
reception put me in solitary i bounced
out after 13 days my lawyers drove me up
there dropped me off
came back picked me up
brought me back
and so can i can i ask you what you're
doing on skid row on a monday morning
yeah
i'm one of my new films i'm writing is
called four corners it's um it's a
a little bit it starts very much like a
little bit like romeo and juliet it's
a clash between the world of uh cartel
drug dealers and uh [ __ ] prostitutes
on santa monica boulevard and throughout
the first act we you know we see the the
heroine of the film
she's having lunch once a week with this
kind of grisly looking older guy
and
at the same time she's been having sex
with this cartel drug dealer so your
persona that you have today is this
something that you
do for for your own enjoyment or is it
part of a movie
you know it's it's really both uh steffi
my female side is a character i've
developed
and i live her life like she's a regular
living person and so i test all the time
what it's like to be a trans person and
i
she only dresses super you know [ __ ]
super revealing
she has no fear of anything you know
much like kane has no fear
um she is um
you know sex queen you know she just she
loves sex and she's
fun and she's witty and interesting and
so you'll come down here and meet
interesting oh yeah
oh yeah i mean
i go everywhere with you know as her
sometimes i switch back and forth i'll
do i'll go i'll three or four times a
day sometimes i'll be steffy and then
kane stephanie and kane depending on
what i'm doing
um but steffy's film four corners
is super cool because when the bad guy
kill that trendy prostitute
my character goes full [ __ ] he goes
from being looking like a mercenary with
a beard and the whole thing he goes from
that
to fully looking like this
for revenge
it's awesome um you know it all for the
leads are trans people
i'm staying really true to that
population
and um and so i'm doing to a certain
extent
by living that life i'm i'm feeling what
it's like to be a trendy prostitute
but if you weren't doing the film you'd
still be oh you know i like walking
around i like talking to people in
different you know states of mind yeah
you met you met somebody last night i
did i met uh
last night
this
you know it's an amazing thing but um
i had i had conjured up in my mind the
perfect
person for me
to be married to
i've been single now for eight years and
i haven't really dated other than
someone i recently
ended a relationship with about two
months ago
and this young woman walks into my
apartment
at like two in the morning
and seven minutes later i asked her to
move in with me
and 12 months after that i gave her an
engagement ring
everyone in my office who was there
working 10 people working i posed right
in front of everyone and gave her a
diamond engagement ring
she is from ohio name's willow
she is perfect
she i mean like perfect so it was like
trying on a suit in a giant warehouse
full of suits
i put on the fursuit and it was perfect
so i bought it
and that was it so you're getting
married yeah
yeah to somebody you met
yesterday
yesterday and
and she's 26
from ohio
she wants to be a pop singer she's got
some talent
development she's transgender female she
is transgender she's tr she is that she
is a transgender female
when i'm steffi i'm a i am a female as
well i'm not
in my mail state of mind
but it's pretty easy now for me to flip
back and forth
it doesn't you know
15 minutes and i can go full steffy or
full cane
your employees understand you and get
you and all that they do
yeah my
my office is pretty avant-garde kind of
reminds me of andy warhol's factory i've
made
everything in that apartment into art
everything it doesn't it doesn't get in
the way of your productivity do not let
this crazy life no i can you know i can
write scripts and tell stories anywhere
on the planet anytime i want you know i
do it on my iphone i sit there and
dictate while i'm surfing or
when i'm scuba diving you know when i'm
up top
um you know i have all the time i want
you know part of this because i don't
follow that concept of time you know
where i have to get up a certain time
and go to sleep at a certain time
so my days tend to last between 28 and
35 hours in terms of my being awake the
whole time and that's not artificially
altered i don't use alarm clocks i don't
use any substances stay awake
i do yeah i do do drugs
i do drugs as a tourist so if i find a
drug i haven't done i'll try it
and maybe try it a couple of times to
see what it's like
so i've tried all of them the only one i
haven't tried is fentanyl and i actually
did try that inadvertently about three
weeks ago when someone gave me
what i thought was a rock of cocaine and
instead it was fentanyl and the person
who i was with took a hit and they
collapsed i had to use five cans of
narcan to save their life
as well as heart compressions
i didn't feel it
i took a hit on the same thing as my
friend did
and didn't feel it at all
so
drugs i don't really get along only from
the perspective of i don't seem to feel
it the same way that other people
describe to me that they feel it
which i find is strange but you know
maybe that's just my physiology i don't
know i'm sitting there with people that
are doing serious drugs
serious drugs and i can keep up with
them and not feel it i mean like
like
yeah
so um
now then back to work i unretired
a week ago
so
i decided to
it was time because the pandemic is
ending i can get production insurance
again
so
going back to seal when i got rearrested
on probation violation for trespass um i
spent the next six months in jail so
there's a gap of about a year and then
six more months in jail and during that
six months i raised against the 10
million budget for seal 7.5 million in
equity from
other inmates who were in the same dorm
as i
one of those investors
recently was murdered
about five blocks
from my apartment
they thought it was fentanyl poisoning
accidental but the word on the street is
otherwise
so i'm honoring his memory by
dedicating the film to him
a lovely guy met him in jail
question jumper
african-american
uh self-made
millions and millions of dollars of
assets
um and and very
discreet about it and very kind to
um so it's a real loss
um
so you've lived a very interesting life
yeah have do you have any regrets
um i i do
um
i regret
it yes i do i i would say would regret
getting getting married to my first wife
except i got my daughters and they're
wonderful
so i wouldn't say that that was regret
for her it's just that the world changed
and it required my wife to follow my
lead into a battle that was pretty rough
it was um
you know when the banks all collapsed
back in
2008
where it started with the whole thing
the big short um you know i was living
in calabasas across from the kardashians
in a mansion that i built
so when the banks
all started shutting down they shut down
my lines of credit
and they tried to foreclose on my house
which was now way underwater
i fought them all the way to the
courthouse steps 17 months in a row they
tried to sell my house
beat them back
in the end we were able to keep the
house they reduced my first by
like a million and a half dollars and
then fixed it at one percent
for forty years and waived my second
nine hundred thousand waived it
so i righted my ship
and
i have no debt now i can live
literally on almost nothing
and um
you know i saw my art collection i still
have a lot of the things i cared about
but they're
you know the things that are beautiful
to hang on the wall you can't trade that
for food when you're hungry
you know and there's a lot of people
that work for me that are hungry you
know these every single person who's
currently working for my company is
either homeless
i've given them a place to live
so not homeless anymore
or they're uh felons
i'm a felon
i'm not dangerous to anyone
you know i did it to
took a deal to avoid going to prison
taking that risk in my age
of now 60. um
there there are people there who who are
prostitutes
and um
and now they're not prostituting
themselves because they found something
to do that is covering their expenses
and that's good and that's making a
difference in their life
it's sort of like having a a tomato
plant you know and planting in in in a
good soil instead of bad soil you know
giving enough water and caretaking in
in
placing the sun the right way
the incredible talents inside every
human being
are then magnified and enhanced to make
you the best person you can be
and then the flip side of that is the
your qualities that drag you down i i
help them to minimize them like their
achilles heel
we find ways to deal with the things
that are
have driven them to drugs alcohol sex
um homelessness despair and now they
have hope
you know they have hope it's it's an
amazing thing that's happening in my
office right now
and um
and i'm grateful
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in all of this
you know i'm an intensely loyal person
and i never give up and i find smart
solutions for problems
i think the most important lesson is
you know be optimistic and happy you
only have one life
love that life
it can be taken from you anytime
love it
revel in it enjoy it we do life
exactly opposite from what we should be
doing
when you're 75 or 80 years old and
you're retired you're just not going to
have as much fun as when you're 40.
so
you know i retired for four years i can
produce movies until the day i die i can
literally all i need
is my iphone that's it
in my mouth to work in my brain work
and i have stories to tell that are
going to blow your mind because i've
lived those stories i've
i've done those things
and when you when you really live and
you don't watch and it's one of the
reasons i don't have tv when you really
live life and you're not observing life
through the eyes of others
you get a totally different experience
and that's an experience that
dramatically alters your landscape your
perception of
you know what you're doing you know why
you're doing it
and
it's required a lot of faith on my part
in people i will not lie i've had
i have very strict house rules in my
apartment including don't bring a gun
and in the three months since i reopened
for you know my doors for business and
allowed people to come back into my life
i've had eight people bring guns into my
apartment
i've had
two fistfights
four people have come through there have
died
in less than three months four people
have come in
for whatever reason left and died
i've my closet which had six shirts six
pairs of pants and six jackets is now
bursting at the scenes with
clothing we're opening up a boutique
online
to accommodate all this amazing
one-of-a-kind
clothing we've been we've been
obtaining i don't even know how we're
getting it but it's in my closet
and
we're gonna sell it for the best price
not the lowest price
so we're um we're doing some really
innovative things and
you know
the people that are living and working
there they're literally sleeping
on the floor or on a chair or on a couch
there's only one bedroom and i'm in the
bedroom i have people sleeping on the
floor on either side of the bed
just so that people have
you know a place to lay their head at
night because they're homeless otherwise
and so why be homeless i got laundry
i've got bath bathroom with a shower
i've got a full kitchen i stock with
food why don't you stay here
and be part of something be be here be
part learn about
you know
filmmaking learn about life i put the
pages for my movie all over the
apartment you just look at the
at the at the covers and there's a page
from the film about
the director and about the producer and
about the synopsis of the movie and
and it's so exciting to watch that come
together you know it's like having your
baby be born watching it you know
so um
yeah this is this is literally the most
exciting time of my life yesterday was
one of the best days i've ever had
it's not over i'm still doing this my
new wife is uh
at my apartment
meeting my friends who she's meeting for
the first time today who
like literally yesterday i didn't even
know her well let me let me let you get
out of here and start your honeymoon
again yeah thank you i'm taking her into
thailand for the honeymoon good for you
yeah thank you all right steffie thank
you so much for sharing your story
any time i wish you guys a lot of luck i
appreciate you're super interesting yeah
appreciate it
when uh
when you're not doing this did you have
is this your full-time gig i do this a
lot yeah
you